[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
immer wieder gibt es kleine
bergungswunder in den Erdbebengebieten
aber die Chance wird geringer
verzweifeltes warten auf Hilfe in Syrien
sind viele Erdbebenopfer sich selbst
überlassen in der Türkei finden Retter
immer seltener Überlebende
Bekenntnis zu Europa in Brüssel bedankt
sich der ukrainische Präsident selenski
für die Unterstützung und wirbt für eine
starke Allianz gegen Putin
Spiel mit Farbe und Licht die Bilder des
Niederländers Jan Vermerk gelten als
Meisterwerke zu sehen ab morgen in einer
großen Ausstellung in Amsterdam
[Musik]
jeden Tag steigt die Zahl der
Erdbebenopfer mittlerweile sind in der
Türkei und in Syrien mehr als 19.000
Tote bestätigt und um die 70.000
verletzte aber auch mehr Hilfe kommt an
selbst in Syrien wo die politische Lage
humanitäre Unterstützung so schwer macht
schauen wir uns das genauer an
den größten Teil des bürgerkriegslandes
beherrschen die Truppen von Machthaber
Assad im Nordosten kontrollieren die
Kurden einen Autonomiegebiet und im
Norden und Nordwesten haben Rebellen
Milizen und Islamisten das sagen sie
beherrschen Teile der Provinzen Aleppo
und icliff dort ist die Lage nach dem
Beben besonders verheerend goldene atai
berichtet
tinderis Nordwest Syrien die
zivilschutzhelfer der weißhelme die
eigentlich Bombenopfer Bergen haben
keine Hoffnung mehr lebende zu finden
sie fragen sich warum immer noch so gut
wie keine internationale Hilfe hier
eingetroffen ist viele suchen nach Essen
selbst Brot ist Mangelware geworden
die Vereinten Nationen hätten den
Ausnahmezustand für Nordwest Syrien
aufrufen und so unbürokratisch so
unparteiisch wie möglich Hilfe an die
betroffenen liefern müssen einmal mehr
sind die UN gescheitert
Hilfe für die vier Millionen vor dem
Assad-Regime geflogenen Syrer hier wurde
schon vor dem Beben immer weniger
Russland und syriens Machthaber
erlaubten zuletzt nur diesen einen
Grenzübergang dafür heute ist der
endlich offen aber in den LKW liegen nur
Decken und hygienesets für 5000 Menschen
kein räumungsgerät keine Rettungsdienst
dabei sagen selbst die UN das Suchen und
Bergungen nur in fünf Prozent des
Katastrophengebietes in Nordwest Syrien
derzeit stattfinden
in Aleppo im regime-gebiet sollen
100.000 Menschen ohne Obdach sein Helfer
und Einwohner kritisieren den Staat weil
er jede Hilfslieferung kontrolliere und
manipuliere
die Menschen wollen essen und wir können
nicht mal unseren Familien im
Krankenhaus Essen bringen weil wir das
an euch geben müssen und dafür eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung der Behörden
brauchen warum können wir nicht
Selbsthilfe austeilen das Volk vertraut
euch nicht mehr
mindestens acht Länder haben Damaskus
mittlerweile Hilfen geschickt wie viel
davon wirklich bei den Menschen ankommen
wird ist unklar
jetzt in die Türkei das Ausmaß der
Zerstörung dort zeigen Satellitenbilder
ein Blick auf die Stadt an tagia vor dem
Beben jetzt liegen dutzende Häuser in
Trümmern mehrstöckige Gebäude zu
Schutthaufen zusammengestürzt oder das
Stadion von Karaman Maras eins
Sportstätte heute Zeltlager und Zuflucht
in der Not auch in dieser Stadt wurden
viele Häuser zur tödlichen Falle sie
liegt im Epizentrum des Lebens dass eine
Fläche traf so groß wie Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg zusammen über Tag 4
der Katastrophe in der Türkei Alexandra
Vacano
überlebt sie haben es geschafft aber
jetzt leben sie auf den Straßen von
Karaman Maras Tag und Nacht eine heiße
Suppe gegen den Hunger und die Kälte
hier bleiben oder woandersschutz suchen
das überlegen Sie hier
in Adana leben die Menschen bereits in
einer Zeltstadt die Kinder könnten vor
Angst nicht schlafen erzählt Elif nur
Aydin
unsere Häuser wurden bei dem Erdbeben
beschädigt werden möglicherweise
abgerissen also warten wir ab es ist
kalt wir brauchen Heizgeräte hier
Lebensmittel und Kleidung jetzt können
wir nur noch ein Feuer anzünden um uns
warm zu halten
zählte errichten dafür sorgen türkische
Soldaten in der Küstenstadt Iskenderun
und die heiß ersehnte Hilfe sie kommt
langsam aber über der Stadt immer noch
Rauchwolken Container im Hafen hatten
nach dem Beben Feuer gefangen
Militärflieger versuchen zu löschen
auf der anderen Straßenseite wartet eine
neue Gefahr Container im Hafen stehen
seit drei Tagen in Flammen jetzt kommt
giftige Substanzen über die langsam
entstehende Geisterstadt
hier in karaman-marash heben Sie Gräber
aus Weinen beten
es ist der Weltuntergang es gibt
tausende verletzte und tote sehen Sie
das sind neue Gräber wir haben bereits
begonnen Menschen hier zu begraben
glauben Sie mir es gibt keine Familie
mehr die nicht leidet
aber dann geschehen hier auch noch diese
Wunder 80 Stunden nach dem Beben retten
sie einen 9-jähriges Mädchen und ihren
Vater
auch Ahmed ein kleiner Junge schafft es
raus aus den Trümmern in adiamanen
wie auch Yusuf in Gaziantep Rettung nach
70 Stunden
mittlerweile sollen 100.000 Helfer und
Helferinnen in der Türkei im Einsatz
sein unter den vielen Freiwilligen sind
auch 40 Rettungskräfte der
Hilfsorganisation Isa aus Duisburg unser
Reporter an seinem Stern hat erlebt wie
sie seit Tagen versuchen eine Frau aus
den Trümmern zu bergen Michael Verlad
violand fast seine Bilder zusammen
dort unten sieben Meter tief unter den
Trümmern in der Dunkelheit liegt eine
Frau gefangen das Helferteam versucht
unermüdlich zu ihr zu gelangen wir sind
jetzt seit fast 36 Stunden und befreien
aktuell sind die Kollegen an der letzten
Platte da werden wir dann mal ein Loch
bohren die Kamera reinhalten gucken wie
wir weitermachen doch der Weg zu ihr
bleibt versperrt von Schutt und Beton
wird ein Trümmerteil bewegt könnte ein
anderes rutschen auch für die Retter
besteht Lebensgefahr es ist ein Rennen
gegen die Zeit
gibt immer wieder Fälle wo auch noch 14
Tagen nach zehn Tagen noch Personen
unter Trümmern gerettet werden kommen
das hängt dann immer von der Situation
ab sind wie alt sind sie welchen
Gesundheitszustand gerade konnte diese
Frau mit ihrer Schwester sprechen für
diese Gelegenheit ist sie den Rettern
dankbar
sie machen gute Arbeit wir selbst haben
seit vier Tagen nicht geschlafen die
ersten zwei Tage war niemand hier jetzt
ist es besser Gedanke ist halt auch von
uns da gewesen der Schwester einfach
noch mal Mut zu geben ja also wenn ich
mir vorstelle meine Familie nicht da
irgendwo also dann würde ich auch hin
wollen die Schwester verbringt wie viele
Menschen in Curry kann die eiskalten
Nächte draußen kein Strom keine Heizung
aber die meisten denken nur an die
Vermissten
unter der Erde konnten die Helfer die
Frau zumindest mit Wasser versorgen sie
sprechen immer wieder mit ihr damit sie
nicht aufgibt genau wie die Retter
und dort in currican sind wir mit Anselm
Stern verbunden an sein wie geht es
jetzt weiter wird auch über Nacht
versucht Trümmer wegzuräumen und die
Frau zu bergen
ja Barbara die Rettungskräfte aus
Deutschland mit denen wir schon so lange
unterwegs sind jetzt die sind fest
entschlossen auch diese Nacht
durchzuarbeiten so wie es die letzten
Nächte auch gemacht haben sie wollen das
Leben der Frau unbedingt retten ihre
Einsätze sind brandgefährlich ihre
Einsätze sind extrem schwierig und
belastend in diesem Fall mussten sie
sieben Meter tief graben um zu der Frau
zu gelangen und auf dem Weg dorthin
haben Sie mehrere Leichen gefunden
möglicherweise Familienangehörige der
eingeklemmten Frau möglicherweise so
sagen sie uns Kinder der eingeklemmten
Frau also sehr belastende Einsätze nicht
nur für die Opfer die natürlich auch
durchhalten müssen um es zu überstehen
aber auch sondern auch für die
Einsatzkräfte sehr belastend das sind
erschütternde Berichte wie sind deine
Eindrücke wie geht's den Menschen vor
Ort
die meisten Menschen hier in der Region
haben nichts mehr als wir heute morgen
hier in die in der Stadtzentrum gefahren
sind haben wir ganz ganz viele Menschen
gesehen Familien gesehen die auf der
Straße die bitterkalte Nacht überstehen
mussten haben sich mit Feuer und warm
gehalten teilweise waren da fünf Leute
und die hatten nur zwei Decken also
wirklich schlimme Verhältnisse hier und
klar ist natürlich auch diese Menschen
die werden noch sehr sehr lange auf
Hilfe angewiesen sein denn es gibt hier
nichts kein Strom kein Abwasser keine
Heizung keine Läden also es ist wirklich
schlimm was die Menschen hier in dieser
Erdbebenkatastrophe zu durchleiden haben
danke an seinem Stern danke und alles
Gute an
das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet als am Montag die
ersten Nachrichten vom Erdbeben kamen
setzte sich direkt das große Rad der
Hilfsbereitschaft in Bewegung auf der
ganzen Welt wurden und werden
Freiwillige und Spenden
zusammengetrommelt und koordiniert auch
in Deutschland ist das Engagement
weiterhin groß Oliver deuker und Svenja
Domeyer berichten
2000 Feldbetten Schlafsäcke zählte
Isomatten und Heizgeräte aus den
Beständen des Technischen Hilfswerks
insgesamt 50 Tonnen Material die mit
drei Bundeswehr Maschinen in die
türkische Großstadt gaziante geflogen
werden wir haben die Kapazität wir
richten uns derzeit äh auf drei
Flugzeuge pro Tag 1 bis Ende nächster
Woche erstmal da müssen wir sehen können
aber unsere normalen Auftrag auch
weiterhin erfüllen aufgrund von
Platzproblemen in gaziante landen die
Maschinen auf der 230 km Entfernung
warme Kleidung Windeln Babynahrung alles
was gebraucht wird wenn man alles
verloren hat wird in dieser Halle in
Hannover gesammelt sortiert und verpackt
wirklich Artikel Kinderkleidung und
tatsächlich Geld spenden damit wir die
LKWs bezahlen können damit die Sachen
die wir auch gesammelt haben
Weiterkommen an die 100 Freiwillige sind
gekommen um zu unterstützen vor allem
hier lebende Türken aber auch deutsche
und Helfer vom ukrainischen Verein die
hier für ihre Landsleute schon seit
Monaten Spenden organisieren wenn die
Menschen leiden egal ob das von Erdbeben
kommt und davon Krieg also wenn die
Menschen leiden dann muss geholfen
werden dann muss müssen Menschen die
deren besser geht einfach für
die deren nicht so gut geht einfach da
sein und einfach helfen drei LKW sind
schon unterwegs ins Erdbebengebiet soll
morgen ankommen drei weitere Staaten
heute
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat den
vielen Menschen in Deutschland Trost
zugesprochen die in den Erdbebengebieten
Familie oder Freunde haben in einer
Videobotschaft sagte er wir sehen euer
leid wir hören euer klagen euer Schmerz
ist unser Schmerz Steinmeier dankte
allen die hilfeleisten und machte
deutlich dass diese Mitmenschlichkeit
noch lange gefragt sein werde die
Menschen denen das Erdbeben alles
genommen hat brauchen jetzt unsere Hilfe
und sie werden unsere Solidarität und
unsere Unterstützung auch dann noch
brauchen wenn die Bilder von der
Katastrophe wieder von anderen
Nachrichten verdrängt werden
unsere Mitmenschlichkeit ist gefragt
und sie bleibt gefragt
wenn Sie helfen möchten können Sie
spenden beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN lautet
de65/100-400-100-400 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien alle
Informationen auch unter Spenden zdf.de
oder im ZDF Text auf Seite 890
auch die EU wird Ihre Hilfe für die
Erdbebengebiete ausbauen das
Versicherten die 27 Staats- und
Regierungschefs am Rande des
Sondergipfels in Brüssel dort sollte es
eigentlich zwei Tage um Migration gehen
doch zunächst zog der ukrainische
Präsident die Aufmerksamkeit auf sich
und auf den Krieg Isabel Schäfers
ein Platz ist noch frei auf dem
eu-familienfoto alle warten auf ihn
wolodineski mit schönen Bildern und
warmen Worten hatte er wohl gerechnet
aber er bekommt heute mehr so zumindest
seine Lesart
ich habe gehört dass man dazu bereit ist
uns die nötigen Waffen und die
Unterstützung zukommen zu lassen auch
die entsprechenden Flugzeuge
welche Länder diese Bereitschaft gezeigt
haben sollen blieb offen die Lieferung
von Kampfjets ins Kriegsgebiet eine
Diskussion die vor kurzem für viele noch
undenkbar erschien doch nun findet sie
statt
finden unter strenger Geheimhaltung
statt erst wenn sie abgeschlossen sind
werden Ankündigungen gemacht der Grund
dafür ist dass der Feind nicht mehr als
nötig informiert sein soll
ich plädiere dafür dass jeder tun sollte
was er kann denn mit jedem zögern mit
jeder Verzögerung wird der Preis steigen
dabei ist bisher nicht einmal klar wer
nun wie viele der versprochenen Leopard
Panzer liefern wird Deutschland versucht
das federführend zu organisieren wir
sind sehr schnell und Deutschland
leistet ein ganz zentralen Beitrag dazu
dass wir eine schnelle Unterstützung
gewährleisten wie auch in der
Vergangenheit am Morgen hatte selenski
vor dem Europaparlament gesprochen und
Umfassung gerungen
[Applaus]
aus Brüssel nimmt er die vielen
Solidaritätsbekundungen für sein Land
mit und positive Signale für mehr
militärische Unterstützung
die Inflation in Deutschland bleibt hoch
nach einer ersten Schätzung des
Statistischen Bundesamts legte sie
gegenüber dem Vorjahresmonat um 8,7% zu
im Dezember lag die Inflation bei 8,6
Prozent da hatte der Staat die
Abschlagszahlung für Gas und
Fernwärmekunden übernommen und das hatte
die Teuerung gedämpft wegen der hohen
Inflation fordern die Beschäftigten im
öffentlichen Dienst von Bund und
Kommunen ein deutliches Lohnplus in
mehreren Bundesländern gab es deswegen
größere Warnstreiks wie hier in
Düsseldorf demonstrierten Mitarbeiter
von Kliniken Verwaltung oder der
Stadtreinigung auch viele Kitas blieben
zu die Gewerkschaften fordern 10,5% mehr
Lohn mindestens aber 500 € mehr
das Mädchen mit dem Perlen Ohrring
dieses Bild gehört zu den berühmtesten
Meisterwerken der Welt gemalt vor über
350 Jahren vom niederländischen Künstler
Jan vermehr was macht die Magie seiner
Malerei aus das Erforschen derzeit
Wissenschaftlerinnen in Amsterdam denn
dort startet morgen eine große
vermehrausstellung Gunnar Krüger
berichtet
von irgendwo kennt man den doch diesen
Blick auf die Stadt Delft in den
Niederlanden er ist genau ein Motiv des
Jan Vermeer von dem 1695 Verstorbenen
Maler sind weltweit nur 37 Werke bekannt
davon versammelt das Reichsmuseum nun so
viele wie nie zuvor
mehr sind alle die Highlights der Museen
die sie uns geliehen haben und
das ist schon ein Akt ein solches Bild
dann auszuleihen insofern sind er so
froh dass wir jetzt 28 hier haben und
damit eben noch einmal diese Chance
bieten
mit so viel Bildern kennenzulernen es
ist auch die Chance sie zu durchleuchten
Restauratoren machten Reisen in des
Künstlers Kopf mit bildgebender Technik
die etwa hinter dem Milchmädchen ein
Wandregal aufspürte
hatte vermehrt es übertüncht damit der
Blick allein auf sie fiel
folgt man eigentlich ein bisschen dem
Gedankengang des Künstlers und vermehrt
auch ein Künstler der ganz viel
verändert während des Malprozesses also
wir kennen keine Zeichnung und so weiter
also er entwickelt seine Komposition
natürlich in seinem Kopf aber eben auch
auf der Leinwand wer war vermehrt sah er
so aus war er auch so reich er hatte 14
Kinder meinte im Jahr zwei Bilder die
sich gut verkauften aus einem Grund weil
vermehrt man den Eindruck dass man
tatsächlich vor einem Raum steht jemand
betreten möchte oder das Licht so
natürlich ist und das Licht alles
miteinander verweht was er dort zeigt
mein notiere also der Meister des Lichts
bis Juni in Amsterdam
ein anderer Meister seine Songs kennen
sie alle seinen Namen möglicherweise
nicht bird bäckerack gestern ist der
Komponist im Alter von 94 Jahren
gestorben
preisgekrönt war der New Yorker einer
der erfolgreichsten popkomponisten aller
Zeiten
[Musik]
diann Warwick einer der vielen
Superstars Designer Hits in alle Welt
trugen
dirigierte und gern saß er auch selbst
am Klavier bis ins hohe Alter
sehr schön jetzt DFB-Pokal das letzte
Achtelfinale gestern Dortmund ist weiter
ja durch den 2:1 Sieg in Bochum was für
ein mitreißendes Revier Derby der VfL
kämpferisch der BVB cool packende Szenen
eine hoch umstrittene
Schiedsrichterentscheidung und ein Tor
der Kategorie ja gibt es denn sowas nach
Spielzeit
sich über dieses Geschenk und trifft zum
1:0 aus und 50 Metern Entfernung nach
der Pause ist Bochum voll da Stürmer und
wie alt versucht's gleich zweimal
scheitert an Gregor Kobel größter
Aufreger der Partie dieses Handspiel von
beino gittens minutenlange Prüfung
umstrittene Entscheidung Elfmeter Stöger
zum Ausgleich 6 Minuten später
Bellingham auf den
eingewechseltens entstand für Bochum
nach fünf Spielen die erste
Heimniederlage für Dortmund die
Eintrittskarte ins Pokal Viertelfinale
zur Ski Alpin WM in Frankreich heute der
Super-G der Männer ohne eine deutsche
Spitzenplatzierung dafür aber mit einer
faustdicken Überraschung ein Außenseiter
aus Kanada siegt mit nur einem
Wimpernschlag Vorsprung
Jubel bei jamescraft über den größten
Triumph seiner Karriere er ist ein
überraschungs Weltmeister bei der
alpinen Ski-WM triumphiert der
25-Jährige Kanadier mit einem denkbar
knappen Vorsprung im Super G auf der
Piste von Mary Belle hundertstel Sekunde
Vorsprung genügend Gold zu gewinnen der
Norweger Alexander kann Silber bejubeln
und Alexi pantoro aus Frankreich Bronze
bei seinem Heimspiel der beste deutsche
Fahrer ist heute andreas Sander auf
Platz 9 womit Baumann landet auf Platz
auf Rang 29
superstarter gegen für das deutsche Team
bei der Bahnrad EM in der Schweiz
gestern Abend immer Hinze Pauline
Grabosch und Lea Sophie Friedrich
setzten sich im Sprint Finale gegen
Großbritannien durch und verteidigten
ihren Titel und zuvor hatte der 20 Jahre
alte Tim torn toitenberg im
Ausscheidungsrennen die erste deutsche
Goldmedaille bei dieser EM geholt
ja du darfst gerne weitergehen aus
deutscher Sicht auch ein schöner Name
danke schön das Wetter bringt morgen
Sonne im Süden und Wolken im Norden die
Details hat gleich erst den Herrn
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie um 9:45
Uhr im heute journal danke für Ihr
Interesse einen schönen Abend noch und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Hochdruck
Brücke über Europa bekommt eine Delle
und dann kommt von Norden einige Wolken
ins Land ja die können im Norden an
Dichter sein und in der Nacht vor allem
im Westen da kann es vorübergehend auch
mal glatt werden denn hier gibt es etwas
sprühring in den höheren Lagen dann auch
schneegrisel das ist alles nicht viel
aber dort wo es niederschlag gibt ist
eben Glätte möglich nach sühnen klartis
auf dort ganz schön kalt Temperaturen
bis -12 Grad in der Südhälfte und drei
Grad in Schleswig-Holstein ja und morgen
dann viel Sonne entlang der Donau nach
lokalen Nebelfeldern nach Norden ist es
Dichter bewölkt und es kann mal
rauströpfeln aus der dichten Wolken
Decke die Temperaturen dazu null bis
acht Grad maximal und die kommenden Tage
ja etwas Regen dann Richtung östliche
Mittelgebirge im Süden Sonnenschein bei
1 bis 10 Grad und danach bleibt es
trocken ein schöner Abend